My name is Aaron Williams, and
I'm a senior data scientist
at the Urban Institute.
I make fake data for a living.
In some scientific circles,
this would be a huge
scandal, but for me, it's
an opportunity to
further science.
Administrative data.
These are data that are
collected for reasons entirely
other than research, like
administering the unemployment
insurance system or
enforcing the tax code,
are incredibly
useful for research,
but understandably have huge
confidentiality concerns.
I work at the Urban Institute.
We're a collection of
economists, sociologists,
criminologists, urban
planners and data scientists
committed to improving the world
through social and economic
policy research.
We would do a lot to
access administrative data,
and we do do a lot to
access administrative data.
But we understand there's
a fundamental tension
between accessing these
data and the confidentiality
of the data.
That's why at the
Urban Institute
we've been working with the IRS
to create fully synthetic tax
data.
Synthetic data
are fake data that
have the statistical
properties of confidential data
and can be used for certain
types of valid analyses
but have much lower
confidentiality concerns
because the data are fake.
You can think of this as
deep fakes for tax research.
In this talk, I'm
going to try and make
the case that administrative
data are very useful
but are difficult to access.
I'm going to share how
we're working with the IRS
to safely expand access
to administrative data
for research.
And I'm also going to
talk about an R package
that we're developing that makes
it easier to synthesize data.
Administrative data are useful,
and I'll give you two examples.
The first example comes
from March of 2020.
It was a scary
time when there was
a health crisis and an
economic crisis unfolding
at the same time.
One issue, though, is that a lot
of our indicators for the labor
market are backward looking.
And so there's one
indicator, one number
that came from the
administrative data
that I think painted
an excellent picture
of the labor market.
Many people had
never heard of it,
but it ended up in a
dramatic data visualization
on the cover of
the New York Times.
This is initial weekly
unemployment insurance claims.
If you look at the bottom
left, that starts in 2000
and it bounces about
from 2000 to 2020.
And then there's
this black swan event
that just shows
how scary of a time
it was in our labor market.
I'll give you another example.
In 2013, Raj Chetty,
Emmanuel Saez and coauthors
released groundbreaking
research about intergenerational
mobility in the United
States, using data
from 40 million
anonymized tax records.
This was really
big research that
deals with how Americans
see themselves.
Right? We have that
desire for our children
to be better off than ourselves.
And one of the things
that they found
is that place
matters quite a bit.
So, for example, the
probability that a child reaches
the top quintile of the
national income distribution,
starting from a family
in the bottom quintile,
is 4.4% in Charlotte,
North Carolina,
but 12.9% in San
Jose, California,
I think I said Charlotte,
North Carolina.
San Jose, California.
So, really big deal.
But some people say
that this research never
should have happened.
In a traditional model
with an agency like the IRS,
you do correspondence research.
You have to get your
analysis plan approved.
You may not actually
see the data.
You send off your code.
They run it on the data.
They review the results
and the like.
What Saez and Chetty did
was radical and different.
They actually became
employees of the IRS.
They had to go through an
extensive background check,
have their fingerprints taken,
go through lots of training,
have all their results reviewed.
I've been through this
process, and let me tell you,
it's not pleasant at all.
So the question
is, how can we get
this understanding,
this value, this meaning
from administrative data
without all this
inconvenience, all while
protecting confidentiality?
And that's why we're
working with synthetic data.
If we can create
fake data that match
the statistical properties of
the confidential data, ways
of safely validating the
results from the synthetic data
against the confidential
data, then we
can conveniently unlock
a lot of this potential.
So we've worked with the IRS
to create two kind of 1 and 1/2
data sets, the second one still
a bit of a work in progress.
The first one is called the
supplemental SynPUF, PUF
for Public Use File.
And it's a collection
of information
that the IRS has
about individuals who
don't, have not filed taxes
and do not have an obligation
to file taxes.
It's a novel data
set that's going
to be very helpful
for understanding
the very low parts of
the income distribution.
And the tax economists
that I work with
are pretty excited about it.
Now you may be asking
yourself, the IRS,
what are all these
non-filers doing in here?
What about information
that's gathered
at places that maybe have one
of these out in front of them?
And that's the second
file that we're creating.
It's called the
SynPUF, and it's
representative of all
taxpayers in the United States.
Now, the first file
that I mentioned
had about 20 variables.
This file has more
than 200 variables,
hundreds of thousands
of observations.
And it comes from
a complex survey
with 25 different strata.
Let's consider a much
simpler example for now,
where we have four variables
and two observations.
So that's our
confidential data set.
And the setup of what
we're trying to do
is create a new data set that
has the exact same record
layout.
We're going to employ
a sequential approach
to create this data set.
So the first thing we'll
do is we'll sample sex
with replacement, then we'll
create a predictive model
to predict age
conditional on sex.
Then we'll create
a predictive model
to predict wages,
conditional on sex and age.
And finally, a predictive
model to predict
taxes, conditional on
sex, age and wages.
A lot of predictive models.
And this is where I get
to express my gratitude
for tidymodels and all the
people who have worked on this.
We've heard some great
things about it this morning.
Tidymodels is a
comprehensive framework
for doing predictive modeling
in R, and we use it extensively
and in particular, we
use parsnip quite a bit,
which is an interface
to different machine
learning and predictive
models, and recipes, which
is a really powerful package for
feature and target engineering.
Now in the example
that we're working on,
right, we need to do
three predictive models.
I gave you another
example where we
need to do more than
200 predictive models.
So we could imagine
having an R script
where it's model one
predict, model two predict,
model three predict.
But if you're going to go
All the way to 200 variables,
that's going to become a
real pain really quickly.
So what tidysynthesis
allows us to do
is actually specify a whole
sequence of predictive models
for generating synthetic data.
It also allows us to do a
few things very specific
to tax or to data synthesis.
One is it allows us to
add additional noise
to predicted values for extra
confidentiality protection.
It allows us to specify
constraints in the data.
Things like individual
income can't
exceed family income
or interest income
can't exceed your
personal income.
It also allows us to
predict from our models
in different ways.
And I'll talk about
that more in a second.
So simply put, tidysynthesis.
The goal is all the
power of tidymodels
for data synthesis concisely
with a few special tools.
So what does this
actually look like?
I'm going to show
you how we're going
to synthesize a data set today.
I'm not going to synthesize
unemployment insurance data.
To the relief of many of you,
I'm not going to
synthesize tax data.
We could imagine synthesizing
electronic health records.
Or maybe we're a
business and we're
interested in unlocking
information from our customer
data without sacrificing
the confidentiality
of any individual in our data.
But I'm not going
to do that either.
No instead, we're going to
synthesize penguins data
because penguins
deserve privacy, too.
So we're going to synthesize
the palmerenguins data set.
We already had a good
introduction to this earlier.
Right? So we have information
about species and island
and sex and these numeric
measures, measurements
of the different penguins.
And we're really going to focus
on these numeric variables.
And our goal is to create
synthetic data that
match the layout of
that confidential data.
So we can start asking
ourselves some questions
of what this should look like.
If you have 200 variables,
what order should we use?
Well, tidysynthesis
has a function
that employs different
heuristics that you can use
to determine synthesis order.
In this case, I'm going to
use my extensive knowledge
of penguins, which
is absolutely none
to determine that bill length
is a very important variable.
And then we're going to
synthesize the remaining
variables in order from most
correlated with bill length
to least correlated.
Once we create this
visit sequence object,
it's going to be reused in
a lot of other functions.
What kind of algorithms should
we use for our predictive models?
In this case, we're going
to use a regression tree,
and this is where parsnip
really shines in tidysynthesis.
So we just specify
regression tree implemented
with the rpart engine.
Now we need to specify that for
all of our different models.
And this is where we're
really saving on all that
R code. In this
case, we just specify
that we want to use the rpart
mod for every single variable.
There's three ways
to specify this.
The first one is
like this, where
we use the same model
for all variables.
Alternatively, we
can specify a default
and then override it
for specific variables,
or we can specify a
different model
for every single variable.
What types of feature or target
engineering should we use?
In this case, this is where
recipes really shines in
tidysynthesis.
We can specify any set of
steps in recipes for our synthesis.
In this case, we're not going
to use any feature or target
engineering.
We're just going to use
this helper function,
construct recipes, basically
construct a series of formula.
Finally, how are
we actually going
to come up with synthetic
data from our models?
Now, if you just use
the predict function,
oftentimes you get a conditional
mean or a conditional median.
This actually makes for
really bad synthetic data
because the data
sets that you're
creating don't have adequate
sample variance, right?
You don't have enough variation
in the resulting data.
So in this case, we're going to
use a function called sample R
part.
If you're familiar
with regression trees,
you navigate to your final
node and oftentimes you
might take the
mean of that node.
Instead, we're going to
sample from that final node
to get this prediction
distribution.
So I just walked you through
two of the functions.
There's a lot of other
functions and objects
in tidysynthesis that can
control the synthesis process.
There's noise for
adding additional noise
to predicted values.
There's constraints
for elegantly enforcing
constraints in the data.
And there's replicates
if we actually
want to synthesize more
than one data set, which
can be handled in parallel.
Tidymodels is lazy, right?
You create a bunch of objects,
but a lot of the computation
doesn't actually happen
until you use like a tune
function or a fit function.
And tidysynthesis is
the exact same way.
So much like you have a
workflow in tidymodels,
we have a presynth object where
we bring together everything
and then the actual
hard work starts
when you run the
synthesized function.
This is where you go
check Twitter or get
your cup of coffee.
If you have 200 variables,
maybe let it run overnight.
So I promise that we
are going to synthesize
some penguins data.
And I have a quick
video to show this off.
In the right,
you'll notice we have
about 300 observations.
If we wrote all
this code out, it
might be a few hundred
lines of code.
But in this case, it's only
about 70 lines of code.
I'm going to highlight
everything and click Run here
in a second and you'll see
that it quickly gets down
to the synthesize function.
Now, if you've worked with
the Palmer penguin's data set
before, I want you
to close your eyes
and imagine what that
data set looks like.
This will take about 10
to 12 seconds to run.
And now open your
eyes, unless you
have it perfectly memorized,
hopefully this looks like what
you were seeing in your mind,
right?
This looks like the
penguins data set,
but it's entirely made up.
It's entirely fake.
So we have synthetic data.
We're done, right?
If this is all I had to
do, I'd be very happy.
I'd spend lots of
time by the pool
with a drink and the little
umbrellas and everything
relaxing.
But in reality, I spend
most of my day saying,
have we done a good enough job?
You can imagine looking at
this in a few different ways.
I mean, on the surface, it looks
like the penguins data set.
We can look at the univariate
distributions for the four
numeric variables.
Here I have density
plots for them
where the synthetic
data are in blue
and the confidential
data are in yellow.
And you see that
we pretty closely
recreate the univariate
distributions for each of them.
And in fact, we only
have 300 observations.
So any differences
here could just
be because of sampling error.
We can also look at some
bivariate relationships.
Here I have the relationship
between flipper length and bill
length, flipper length and
bill depth, and flipper length
and body mass.
Again, the synthetic
data are in blue
and the confidential
data are in yellow.
And in all three cases, I
think we do a pretty good job
of recreating the data.
And in fact, if you
fit regression lines,
which I've done here, they
look almost identical.
But maybe we're not satisfied.
Maybe we want to
specify a new synthesis
and start all over again.
The good news is we're not
starting from the beginning.
Just like how in tidymodels
you can reuse objects sort of
over and over and over again.
Here we can re-use all of
our objects from earlier,
add some information
about adding noise
to our predicted values.
Add some constraints
and synthesize.
So just as a recap,
administrative data
are useful but
difficult to access,
and I think there's
a huge potential
to understand more
about our world
if we can make it easier
to access those data.
As a proof of concept,
we've created two
fully synthetic data
sets with the IRS,
and we've built
this package called
tidysynthesis so
that other agencies, nonprofits
and businesses can implement
these methods without
having to write thousands
of lines of code.
Now, the data privacy community,
the synthetic data community
are pretty small,
and especially they
don't have that many
statisticians or data
scientists.
So if this is something that
gets you excited, if you're
interested in joining the
raft of privacy penguins,
please don't hesitate to reach
out to me after this talk here
in person, on Twitter, at
awunderground or on GitHub.
Maybe this could be you.
Thank you.